the bridge of weight is about a good
hand the supports have told us that every
year to change so that it looks beautiful
shining like a source of gold that bridge
that is blamed has been since the Incas
even later we do not oppose pride
with its account
[  Music]
the man in the ether space wall
I direct the people
and a milan or victorian from arizona I am
the construction engineer we are two
males I started on the right hand side
and on this side where history is not
this bridge is natural and we do not use
or  cement nails no kind of
machine and so he abandoned more by hand
no more we moor every year
we always do the second weeks of June
the bridge is made up of four hard
two handrails the bridge is 38 meters
each participant has to bring a 40
stroke obligatory task thing  known for the purpose of
reaching frequency
we do that is to say we cut from cutting
the wings in approaching from drying
chang sing on the ground so that it
becomes a little soft and des  Well, everything is
mixed by wetting it with water, we put the
rope together and we twist it in the wallet and the chalk,
we make the payment, all of it is requested from the
supports for a license, so to
start, it is also still to throw
the earth, so I saw five missions that
cannot pass  we're going to
make the tough alfredos go through anything and then
we just started to visit the story
then we pulled when jhala nath
said it's done it's done they left you
the rope it wasn't dangerous it's
that people are afraid
nervous they wanted nervous and what are you
after  we already started to weave
we find ourselves
inaugurating always singing dancing
like this we inaugurate at the end when we finish
the bridge I like it a lot right now I'm
proud field
I'm happy for you if they change
and I'm nearly 40 years old also
my grandfather is also an actress and him
after my grandfather my  father and me until
now is next
forever forever we will keep
is my sharp about my maest  I want to
weave the bridge with this bridge
you make us proud long life of the bridge
[Music]